let's let's let's let's move to uh u.s
media real quick because i want to
advance the conversation
we have this tweet from glenn greenwald
which is going to blow everybody's minds
oh god
glenn tweeted if if if you're a critic
of the media
you need to hear this glenn greenwald
tweeted read this amazing section from
judge silberman's descent today
in a defamation case before the dc
circuit on how an increasingly
ideological ideologically homogenized us
media
is not only threatening core free speech
values but also the ability to be
informed
in his dissent he wrote it is well
accepted that
viewpoint discrimination raises the
specter that the government may
effectively drive certain ideas or
viewpoints from the marketplace
but ideological homogeneity in the media
or in the channels of information
distribution
risks rep risks repressing certain ideas
from the public consciousness
just as surely as if access were
restricted by the government
to be sure there are few notable
exceptions to the democratic party
ideological
control fox news the new york post the
wall street journal's editorial page
it should be sobering for those
concerned about news bias
that these institutions are controlled
by a single man and his son
will a lone holdout remain in what is
otherwise a frighteningly orthodox media
culture
after all there are serious efforts to
muzzle fox news
and although upstart mainly online
conservative networks have emerged in
recent years
i think it might go on no he so he
doesn't continue from there but i'll
read the next
uh the next section that glenn post he
said it should be born in the mind that
the first step taken by any potential
authoritarian or dictatorial regime
is to gain control of communications
particularly
particularly the delivery of news it is
fair to conclude therefore
that one party control of the press and
media is a threat to a viable democracy
it may even give rise to countervailing
extremism
the first amendment guarantees a free
press to foster a
vibrant trade and ideas but a biased
press can distort the marketplace
and when the media has proven its
willingness if not eagerness
to so distort it is a profound mistake
to stand by
unjustified legal rules that serve only
to enhance the press's power
absolutely amazing to hear that
but maybe it's too little too late but
i'll tell you this it is absolutely true
how sobering as judge silverman
describes it
that the main resistance
to dem democratic orthodoxy in the media
is murdoch so they said one really
old man and his son is that what they're
talking about murdoch's son
lachlan yeah but isn't is lachlan the
one is it isn't he woke or something
yeah it's over everybody uh pack it in
we're going home and uh welcome to your
new cult
i think we're incredibly resilient as
humans so if someone is speaking out
against it that means
that means we have a chance maybe so
it's a dissent i mean is this is is this
too little too late i absolutely think
it is man
maybe maybe not maybe not maybe i'm look
there's a lot of people watching this
show right now
and this is not a a
you know what no no i i was going to say
we're not ideological here but we are
absolutely
ideologically motivated here classically
liberal libertarian and socially liberal
values
represent the conversations we have here
for the most part there's a reason it's
really fascinating
why leftists are so hard to book because
they're they're they're an authoritarian
orthodoxy
it's very hard to speak uh safely
when you exist inside the confines of
their moral framework
that's why i've done numerous interviews
i did an interview in berkeley with this
woman
i'm standing in the street and i'm
filming some woman walks up and starts
talking to me and i'm holding my camera
i asked her some questions she answered
she gave horrible answers
five minutes later she walks up to me
and says delete the footage
no joke and i said i'm filming and you
walked up to me i'm not deleting it
and she was like no you have to i don't
give you permission and i was like i
don't need your permission
you're in public talking to me while i'm
filming i don't
try to generate controversy though so i
blurt her face i'm not trying to drag
her
i'm not trying to get some random woman
on the street in trouble with the woke
but i did want to show what she had
basically said was
conservatives who get physically
attacked deserve it because of the way
they dress
she said there was a woman wearing a
maga hat she was asking for it
no joke no joke and so the issue there
is when you think about the moral
framework that exists in the minds of
these people when they say
women who are wearing certain clothes
aren't asking for it but when it comes
to trump supporters they are
it shows there's no actual principle
behind their moral framework other than
join the tribe or burn she wanted me to
delete the
delete the footage because her ideas
would get her canceled
when people heard what she said you
can't stick your neck out
so many of these people they do their
shows the priests of the orthodoxy
the guests who have in this show who are
more than happy to come and speak are
confident in themselves
in classically liberal ideals of freedom
of speech
and being and being honest expressing
themselves
and they're not scared about what the
woke mob is going to do to them well
that's i mean i think you're
that's an overstatement for me since i
have a very low self-esteem which is why
i got into media so that my parents
would notice who i am
there you go as as for most of these
journalists who work at mainstream
publications
um yeah you know that's interesting and
that's
that dissent you know i don't as as
ground-breaking as that may be or
shattering as that may be
if that were say any other if there were
a celebrity that had like say a red pill
moment
it said something like that maybe okay
sarah silverman
yeah she came out recently and said i
don't want to be associated with either
party
because of the elitism and the
absolutely well uh what's her name
um oh that name is escape rose mcgowan
oh yeah definitely when she had her
moment that was big
that was huge especially in the in the
middle of the presidential election
she's like i don't
what the the accusations of tara reid
against uh then candidate joe biden
uh was enough from and the way it was
handled from
her charmed co-star alyssa milano yeah
that was enough for
her to be like i'm done that's it i want
to be optimistic
right now you know why they're not cool
people
who wants to be like them you know do
you want to be
one of these like easily agitated
panicky finicky woke culture warriors
working for one of these publications
some people but it's remnants of the old
world right so the new york times has
prestige the great was it the gray lady
the paper of record
young people grow up millennials hearing
great stories about the prestigious
the prestigious new york times it is my
dream to be a times journalist
congratulations they hired you and now
you complain about tick tockers
is that what you really thought you were
going to be doing or did you think you
were going to be like
meeting in a parking garage and some
like source walks up and he's got a
manila folder and he's like please
don't tell me when i was here otherwise
they'll kill me and you're like don't
worry
i'm gonna expose these criminals and ah
and then in reality you're like
so this 17 year old on tick tock you're
never going to believe this like as it
take night take
mention right but then like one of his
friends showed up that's what the new
york times
has become who wants to be that today
what young
person who's actually on tik tok is
looking at what what what these
journalists at the new york times are
and going
i really want to be like that when i
grow up they're not doing that
so what's happening now is these these
woke culture warriors of
culture warriors of cancel culture at
these big publications
are not cool and nobody wants to be like
them
young people especially you ever seen
the show the boys
oh yeah yeah of course no it's it's very
uh
i don't know why this conversation
reminds me of that but it's specifically
in the storyline of the first season
with starlight who
is trying to get into the seven of
vaught she wants
it's for those who aren't familiar she's
a she's a superhero she wants
to join the big superhero organization
right yeah so
and then she gets there and she realizes
obviously this is all a big charade you
know this is a
corporate entity they don't care about
like
actually you know saving people's lives
they care about the money flow
yeah and and so you know if you haven't
watched it i highly recommend it
um it is a good show um which i got
off amazon prime because we're now
basically pumping up jeff bezos's
numbers but
but but it's it's it kind of shows that
classical trope of
you know don't meet your heroes right
she she really really wanted to be this
big hero join this big organization and
then she realized it was actually really
awful everyone sucked
yeah and she didn't want to be there
anymore but i think it's i think but
that's like
but that is very much media today isn't
it but it's worse than that
no i know well i mean we're not a
fictional show and comparing
here's what i mean in the show the boys
the seven which is like the justice
league they're cool they're celebrities
everybody wants to be them they're in
the movies they got endorsement deals
who wants to go work for the daily beast
to write about i don't know cats or
something stupid that's nonsensical and
made up
no who wants to be that when they grow
up nobody so so
here's my point we've talked about how
movies today going woke
are becoming like christian films used
to be
you know like good was it good flicks or
whatever uh yeah pure flicks pure flicks
and everybody everybody always laughs
and then like
jokingly ribs me like hey don't make fun
of pure flicks
it's like watching those really like
really campy
religious versions of films with like
bible man or whatever and veggie tales
and stuff
as as these as look as the details as
the woke cult takes over hollywood
movies become preachy boring and
nonsensical
and uncool you gotta watch have you seen
the new craft
no you will absolutely hate it you know
why
i don't care about the wokeness it's not
a good movie
it makes no sense the pacing is off i
have no idea what the message is
and it's just like nothing happens i
guess then a guy burst into flames or
something
the whole movie is a woke psa where they
just keep
giving off woke pot shots of like
they'll be walking on the street and
then one person
makes a comment about being trans and
you're like what does it have to do with
the movie like why is this dialogue in
the film
because they want to make sure you know
they're woke the wokeness is more
important the story line
thus they've created something boring
that nobody wants to engage with
the movie will fail and then kids who
see will grow up thinking
that's not cool i don't want to be like
that if it's not cool it doesn't inspire
youth
it won't it won't exist who are your
heroes
my heroes oh they're mostly rappers but
they're not really heroes
i don't know i mean i i actually no my
i have my heroes are like my dad my
grandpa like my legitimate heroes people
i think are like
through and through the greatest people
i know
and i don't the thing is and that's
exactly what it is
the never meet your heroes i don't have
any like
celebrity heroes but you said rappers i
like rappers
i like i love hip-hop and like their
inspirations and how i can like i love
this song make music
i love them my my my heroes are dave
grohl eddie better
but like i you know
that's the thing is like i'm terrified
of the one you know the potential of
meeting any of them
because of how super flawed but they
still inspire
you it's not oh bro
who are your heroes i don't have any
heroes did you used to never
like growing up you never nope watch
people or no i'm too arrogant
i'm honest i'm not even kidding like i
would i would watch skate videos and
they'll be like a pro who's like the
best in the world
and am i sitting there going i can do
that my friends would be like shut up
you're not gonna tre flip a ten stairs
oh you need to do friends oh yeah
okay and then i would go and throw
myself down the stairs and get hurt
the reason i brought it up i was not i
was not that good but i was certainly
arrogant enough to think i was
my heroes are not these people that
write these pieces i don't think anyone
think looks up to these people and
thinks i want to be like that guy no but
they look at musicians they look at like
great performers
that's the real challenge in life and
and it's mostly a way of how they
think because you know musicians just
generally think a different way they
see sounds you know they they can they
can compose music
they can create stuff out of thin air
and it's
and it just resonates with i think like
it gives you these chills and you hear
it like when you hit effective
song like you ever get chills down your
spine when you hear that all the time
music affects us physiologically right
like
you know the beats it's like and it
affects our brains in certain ways it
triggers emotions
and we like feeling good and we like we
like being made to feel so we
like the people who make us feel that
way but there's something interesting
about it i will say though
we've already met our heroes because of
twitter and they were all awful
look i would never i don't look up to
actors and i don't care for actors i
think they're just actors and i've never
understood the obsession with like
celebrity i've always just been like i
don't care i don't care who cares
brady shaved her head whatever but now
we get to actually meet these people and
we learned
you know chris evans for instance mark
ruffalo they're really nasty people
right chris evans is okay he's kind of
nasty mark ruffalo is one of the meanest
people i've ever i've ever
seen on the internet it's like he just
posts nasty things david cross also a
mean guy
and i'm surprised that how many
comedians and celebrities are just
nasty it's really messed up you look at
joe rogan's twitter what do you see
instagram instagram post of like him
eating steak and like his dog
yes people like joe rogan you know why
because when you see him for who he is
you're like
oh he seems like a cool dude but then
you turn to like some of these other
comedians and movie the actors and stuff
and they're just posting nasty things
screaming posting pictures of
decapitated trump heads and you're like
i don't want to be around that what i
mean
you know this is this is kind of why the
list exists
the list the list of people who should
have their phones taken people should
have their phones taken away because
it's designed to save people from
themselves
and the reason for that is because as
you mentioned people are really nasty
but if you don't enforce the list then
what does the list really do well that's
why i went independent tim
oh yeah there's gonna be there's gonna
be there's gonna be like two guys in
suits showing up to like brian selter's
house knocking on the door and be like
brian
it's it's time and they take his phone
from him boom if i could do that i'd do
that by the way
brian suther specifically i'm looking
for seed money anybody interested
yeah you're launching my twitter you're
launching a network the swaraj
the habibi network yeah so you like just
went
just went live just went like solo yeah
today
today
was today is my final day big dude yeah
so maybe
what you make will actually be something
inspirational to young people and
they'll be like
when i grow up i want to make a list of
people should have their phones taken
away
well the idea is that i don't do it
forever and i have basically no but
you got to pass the list down i gotta
pass the list on but no the whole thing
is like the captain america shield
but listen this is what i'm talking
about the list is important you know why
because it's funny it's hilarious and
people block you when you put them on
the list
for those that aren't familiar by the
way your guests from yesterday chris
schlechter he blocked me because i put
him on the list
nice all right so basically it works if
someone tweets something really dumb
and then if it qualifies for like you
should have your phone taken away for
tweeting that
you'll tweet at them like it's a meme
post there's one there was one i think
of right hand emojis
right there was one of us consuela from
family guy i think one of you
in a truck full of people with a coyote
driving the car
and all the blue checks being taken away
it's funny people see it and they laugh
there's going to be some young kid who's
seeing the world of politics
he sees someone like brian stelter from
cnn tweet something really dumb
like like tucker carlson is the new
donald trump or whatever did you put him
on the list for that one or no
um that's a team take honestly
right right but some kid will see that
post see everybody
laughing and they'll think that's cool
it makes people laugh
it exudes strength and what that person
posted was really dumb
yeah i don't want to be like the person
put on the list i want to be the person
naming people who should be on the list
well it's interesting because i've
gotten criticisms like
i'm a hall monitor or i'm you know i'm
basically waging a harassment campaign
against people which is obviously not
true try more
um i've had people have
meltdowns about me putting them on the
list like
this is the i think of a few people from
very early on i'm talking like december
2019 when this thing was still like in
its in this
infancy and the reason why it came the
reason why i started it was literally
one of those things where you know
kind of your recent twitter habits it's
just like it just came out of thin air
it was
it was george conway dunking on his wife
kellyanne and a quick tweet
he's the lincoln project yeah the
lincoln project guy and
it was like one of those things were
like oh no you should never do that in
public
give me that phone george that is taking
and he is the first person i put at
number one and
he doesn't have a blue check he's not
verified but like everybody thinks is
because
there's everybody the list comes for all
but like there's a higher standard to me
if you're not verified because literally
anybody could just post whatever you
want if you're
not verified if you're verified there's
you know obviously like a standard that
you you you have to listen well yeah you
got the endorsement of twitter
exactly yeah you know so i think some of
the value of your work too is like you
mentioned
the resonation that you feel from a
musician that vibration
also you put yourself on camera and your
voice so you're creating resonance
literal physical resonance it's so
different than just writing
being behind a typing thing and putting
words on the internet
like that's how you really affect people
in my opinion i think this media this
internet video media is so powerful i
prefer
video more in writing every day of the
week that was my strength i mean i was a
commentary video writer
i i mean sorry commentary video editor i
do edit videos but like
they had writer in there i just you know
because i did write from time to time
but like it was
if i it turned out in probably like the
last like three years
of me being at the examiner is that if i
wrote anything it would all
already be a video so like without you
seeing an article is really just like
the script that i had in
in the video so it it is a
better way of reaching people because
most people don't like to read
i mean that's just kind of the way the
world people have very low attention
attention spans
well they can start on a podcast and
then go work on something else exactly
you can apply
podcasts have become so effective that's
why audiobooks have become so
so effective is that you can literally
multitask as you're listening to this
stuff
and if you have to rewind you can rewind
who can you know no one cares yeah
you're free to do it
but people play video games listen to
podcasts they go to work that's very
tough to do i don't know how
you just pause it when they say
something really cool and then go rewind
it and watch
i mean i've done that you know it's like
you're making breakfast or whatever you
turn on a podcast and you said make
breakfast yeah it's like watching tv
but i almost always twitch stream now
when i play video games i don't know i
should probably just
game offline for a bit that's it's gonna
be really interesting the feature
because i see a lot of people like
everybody has a twitch channel
and they'll get like seven live viewers
or whatever and i'm like who are these
like seven people who are watching
instead of playing and doing the stream
themselves and what happens when
everyone does
and then everyone is streaming them
playing a game and no one's watching a
lot of people just have it on in the
background
a lot of people yeah so that's and you
hear people saying like so i'm gonna go
steal this car and then light this
hooker on fire
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at 8
pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time